dann gibt es aber auch die Männer aus
dem Umfeld von Armin Laschet die ganz
treu zu ihm halten aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen zumindest der
Innenminister Herbert Reul und auch sein
Sozialminister sein Gesundheitsminister
Karl-Josef Laumann der sich so geäußert
hat bei den Kollegen vom WDR
offen dass das was an den Laschet in den
letzten Wochen hat über seine Person
ergehen lassen müssen nicht erstaunen
vorstellen dass ein er hat hier eine
sehr gute Arbeit gemacht und ich bin
wirklich
beschäftigt
wie hier finde ich Demokratie
politische Vernichtung eines Menschen
stattfindet und das ist bitter ich finde
so muss politische Auseinandersetzung
auch nicht sein und
will das nur einfach mal sagen weil
es wird auch schon
wirklich nicht wie ich auch anwidert
wieder umgegangen wird also dass man die
Angriffe von politischen Gegner kriegt
das ist ja erstmal normal aber wie man
sie kriegt und dass sie dann auch
teilweise aus den eigenen Reihen kommen
das ist schlicht und ergreifend ein
Zustand der schlimm
ist das so Julian Reichelt wird hier ein
Politiker vernichtet nein das ist
natürlich ein vollkommen unangebrachtes
Vokabular dass der
nordrhein-westfälische
Gesundheitsminister dort findet aber es
ist inzwischen sowas wie der typische
Dreiklang der Politik geworden
unterstützen meucheln im Falle einer
Niederlage und dann beklagen auf Social
Media weil man für solche Videos so
viele Likes so viel Zustimmung bekommt
weil alle sagen ja das Recht das ist
menschlich so schlimm es ist vollkommen
klar in welcher Realität wenn ich
Kanzlerkandidat werde weiß jeder in
welcher Realität ich mich bewege das ist
eine brutale Realität von Machtpolitik
entweder ich gewinne dann bin ich der
König oder ich verliere dann werde ich
vom Hof gejagt das ist Politik das weiß
auch jeder und das jetzt sozusagen diese
selbst Reinwaschung und übrigens Leute
wie ich weiß es jetzt nicht für Herrn
Laumann persönlich aber all die Menschen
die jetzt den menschlichen Umgang mit
Amina schickt beklagen das erleben wir
als Journalist immer wieder reden hinter
den Kulissen komplett anders sagen
hinter den Kulissen was für ein da ist
was für ein Loser ist welche Fehler
gemacht hat und dann stellen sich vor
die Kameras und beklagen den
menschlichen Umgang den sie selber
betreiben den sie selber hinter den
Kulissen betreiben hinter den Kulissen
haben sie das Messer und wenn sie vor
die Kamera treten dann weinen sie Tränen
des Bedauerns und das Mitgefühls das
werden wir jetzt auch das haben wir bei
Andrea Nahles bei der SPD schon erlebt
jetzt werden wir es in den nächsten
Tagen bei Armin Laschet erleben auch das
muss ich sagen ist eine Form von
Wehleidigkeit die glaube ich wenn ich
Deutschland das viertgrößte
Industrieland der Welt regieren will von
den Wählerinnen und Wählern nicht
besonders geschätzt wird man muss
einfach man wenn man man kann nicht
weinen vom Platz gehen auf dem Level ja
das geht einfach nicht sondern man muss
dann tatsächlich auch in der Niederlage
Verantwortung übernehmen und da hat
Social Media tatsächlich schon vieles
verändert in den letzten Jahren weil es
halt so gefeiert wird auf Social Media
wenn ich dann solche rührseligen
laumann-videos da fabriziere in den
getan wird als wäre Armin Laschet
vollkommen unschuldig einfach vernichtet
worden
er wird politisch vernichtet nein er hat
selber erst mal das stolze Wahlergebnis
der stolzen Volkspartei CDU im
Alleingang vernichtet durch seine Lacher
in der Flut durch den vollkommen
unkoordinierten Wahlkampf Amy Laschet
das muss man ja leider sagen hat es
geschafft sich für den gesamten
Wahlkampf keinen einzigen Satz mal
aufzuschreiben der irgendwie im
Gedächtnis geblieben ist ja das ist die
Fehleranalyse die ist jetzt braucht wenn
die Volkspartei CDU weiter eine
Volkspartei bleiben will wenn man sich
statt Fehleranalyse darauf konzentriert
Armin Laschet zu bemitleiden das Mitleid
braucht er auch gar nicht dafür ist er
taff genug dann wird das verheerenden
Schaden bei der CDU anrichten und auch
bei den Wählerinnen und Wählern ich
frage mich all die die gewählt haben und
jetzt erwarten dass er eine Lösung
präsentiert wird die wissen wollen wie
es mit dem Land weitergeht und die jetzt
so ist es ja gerade sehr anschaulich
beschrieben Zeuge werden dieses
machtpokers den wir heute auch
thematisieren was glaubst du was löst
das bei den Menschen aus
ich glaube Patricia das löst gar nichts
mehr bei den Menschen aus weil das was
Armin Laschet damit noch einigen
verbliebenen Getreuen veranstaltet
findet ja vollkommen losgelöst statt von
dem was tatsächlich gerade an
Regierungsbildung stattfindet es wird ja
eine es wird ja über eine Regierung
verhandelt es wird zwischen Erwachsenen
die gute Wahlergebnisse erzielt haben
jetzt über die Zukunft einer deutschen
Bundesregierung verhandelt und das was
Armin Laschet da gerade macht hat damit
eigentlich gar nichts mehr zu tun das
ist nur noch selbst Bespiegelung und
Realitätsverweigerung ich glaube dass
finden viele Menschen vermutlich
befremdlich was die Lage und den Zustand
der Union angeht und
dass die Realitätsverweigerung von Armin
Laschet aber ich glaube da muss man sich
keine Sorge ums Land machen denn es gibt
da ja Parteien die darüber verhandeln
und sich nicht beeindrucken lassen von
ja von dieser Wehleidigkeit
[Musik]